KENNEDY LOST HIS JOB IN 2015.
THE NINTH CIRCUIT JUST DECLINED
HE PLANS TO TAKE THE CASE ON THE
WAY TO THE SUPREME COURT.
COACH KENNEDY DRIVES US ALONG
WITH HIS LAWYER MIKE BERRY.
WHERE DOES IT LEAVE YOU EXACTLY?
>> I WASN'T SURPRISED.
I ONLY GO BY WHAT I HEAR FROM
EVERYBODY ELSE.
IT WAS A LONG SHOT TO BEGIN
WITH.
HOPEFULLY THE SUPREME         SP
HOPEFULLY THE SUPREME         SE
HOPEFULLY THE SUPREME         SC
HOPEFULLY THE SUPREME         SU
HOPEFULLY THE SUPREME         ST
SOLEMNLY WOULD ACTUALLY HEAR THE
CASE.
>> Tucker: WHAT'S AT STAKE
HERE?
IS NOT JUST ABOUT ONE FOOTBALL
GAME OR ONE COACH.
THAT REALLY SETS A DANGEROUS
PRECEDENT NOT JUST FOR THE
COACH, BUT FOR SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THIS DECISION, IF IT'S NOT
CHALLENGED, MEANS THAT IF YOU
IF YOU ARE A MUSLIM EMPLOYEE,
YOU COULD BE FIRED POURING AHEAD
COVERING.
IF YOU'RE A CATHOLIC AND HE WERE
A CROSS NECKLACE, YOU COULD BE
FIRED.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN POURING OUT
SUPPORT AND FOLKS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WANT TO KNOW, WHAT CAN
BE DONE ABOUT THIS?
WHAT CAN WE DO?
WE ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO GO TO
First Liberty.org TO SUPPORT
COACH AND GET THE SUPREME COURT
TO TAKE THIS CASE.
>> Tucker: JOGGED OUR MEMORY.
WHO WAS OFFENDED BY WHAT YOU ARE
DOING QUESTION WORK HARDER TO
GET TO THIS POINT?
>> AND ORIGINALLY STARTED FROM A
COMPLIMENT.
ONE OF THE EDUCATORS SO WHAT
WE'RE DOING ON THE FIELD AND
PAID THE SCHOOL DISTRICT A
COMPLIMENT AND SAID WHAT WE WERE
DOING WAS AWESOME.
IT WAS GOOD SPORTSMANSHIP.
SOMEBODY MUST'VE BEEN OFFENDED
BY IT OR HE WOULDN'T HAVE LOST
HER JOB.
>> THE ONLY PERSON THAT I
REALIZED THAT WAS REALLY
OFFENDED WAS THE DISTRICT
LAWYERS AT THAT TIME.
VICTIM HERE.
THIS IS THE MOST PERVERSE PART.